you are so busy you're doing so much
you're doing hollywood game night
which is a really fun show there's a
great
there's a great vibe on that program
everybody seems to be having
a good time and you're a very congenial
host oh thank you it is it's a good time
you know it's kind of fun nothing deep
nothing crazy just there to have you
know
basically a game night in my house
ostensibly but
of course it's not my house uh-huh oh
they built a house to resemble your
house they did yes an exact
replica if i did was in that situation i
would have them build a house that's far
superior to my house well that is
actually because
well here's a q here's my question for
you so you've got that show
now you've got this uh new show this new
version of weakest link
right that you're doing and it's
interesting to me because i'm
remembering
the previous weakest link there was a
real edge to that show and there's a
real
edge to the host yeah you're i know you
as
very nice jane lynch you're doing
hollywood game night now you're doing
this show that might require a darker
jane lynch is that
is that true that is true yes indeed
and i am here for it i loved it i had so
much fun
dismissing people calling them on their
stupidities
and keeping it a little classy at the
same time i think i can say
so you put people down in a classy
refined way
absolutely they don't even know that
they've been slapped
full across the face so
here's my question which is the real
jane lynch
the happy welcome to my home let's have
a
fun uh game together
or the cruel um the cruel one from
weakest link which one's the real one
the weakest link is my shadow for sure
it is it is what's going on not so far
under the skin
either it's about you have only have to
go about a quarter of an inch to get
that really
dark cutting person and then hollywood
game night it's just all
you know me pretending to be this
affable wonderful welcome to my home
place
and i can only do it for like a couple
hours at a time and then everybody's
gotta leave
everyone's just gotta leave because
you're about to lose it at that point
exactly
have you ever melted down on game night
just someone doesn't get
messes up the game and you forget and
you forget which show you're taping and
you lose it on everything oh yeah
i uh kelly clarkson i grabbed her by the
throat because she was trying to take my
job
she was trying to control the game so i
grabbed her by the throat and i threw
her into the ball pit
no that didn't happen but i wanted to do
that
we're going to edit out the part where
you say that didn't happen because
that's going to make it into a tabloid
yeah you know what i remember from the
weakest link is that that great cutting
line
you are the weakest weakest link
goodbye and and you're oh so that's how
you do it oh you go goodbye
it's like adios amigo or amiga
nice thanks yeah it's really nice to
dismiss them that way and what's really
fun conan is
we've added to uh this iteration of the
weakest link a tunnel
so it's like going into dante's inferno
it's bright red and we've got this
music and they have to walk it's the
walk of shame straight
into the pit of hell and i love every
moment of it
i think this is very good for you
because i have found that
when i'm in a comedy sketch or any time
i've done to do comedy over the years it
required me
to really go after somebody i feel
it's so it's just going to help you
vent all of this this rage that lies
deep within jane lynch it's going to
you're going to vent all of this exactly
and you know your body and your psyche
doesn't know
that you're pretending no and so it's an
actual
relief and it's there's a catharsis and
then you walk away and everybody you
know like the contestants they love
being yelled at they love being shamed
so uh yeah there's no no harm no foul
yeah well sounds like you're a clinical
sociopath
yes indeed um listen uh
i love talking to you and i love that
you
got in the christmas spirit for us and
uh i know you
probably have something to say to andy
now um you know yeah andy are you going
home for christmas we're from the same
hometown too so
you you don't know much about chicago so
i'll ask him are you going home for
christmas
this year andy who knows
yeah he would not be able to do exactly
i might have to
i might have to steal a glider and
escape the us i i would love to come
with you
so if you do please swing by laurel
canyon and pick me up
i will i will it'll be all right because
i'll have the dog too obviously
oh i'd love to see daisy i'd love to see
daisy again and
um just thank you so much conan for
having me on and i'm sorry i can't
include you in this but you're not from
chicago and you don't understand
the whole thing that goes on between us
so
i've been in chicago been a bunch of
times yeah okay
so that's probably as good as being from
there no it is not
and andy guess what i miss you very much
and it's been really nice to talk to you
yeah yeah we will see each other when
this is all
i'm when this is all when it's just the
two of us we can probably uh pick up
where we left off
i mean that goes without saying okay
okay honey i love you love you too
okay are we done conan
yeah okay weakest link
weakest link premieres on tuesday
september 29th
on nbc jane lynch
andy richter i forget my name
conan o'brien i remember thank you thank
you very much
uh really i'm i'm very happy for you
looking forward to this new show
and uh and you're always a delight every
single time thank you so much we bow to
you
christmas merry christmas to you all of
you and a happy new year